you'll never find me in bed at midday
what I know now that I didn't know ten
years ago that getting your eyebrows
done by a professional is life-changing
when I grow old you'll find me growing
flowers in my garden
when I'm in a bad mood I listen to the
greatest showmen soundtrack or the
now-and-then soundtrack both are amazing
part of the day the deeper and the
hotter and the bubblier my bath
when I want to be a badass I will wear a
blazer and heels
on my wedding day you'll find me
laughing and smiling with all my nearest
and dearest
my guilty pleasure is a McDonald's
breakfast with extra hashbrowns
the beauty product I can't live without
is concealer because I was not gifted
with bright under eyes
the thing is that no one ever told me
about being a YouTube star is how many
cool opportunities would ever come from
turning on a camera and making some
videos about things I was interested in
Aaron's bronzer
because I absolutely love those the
zoella beauty shower shake because it's
a good double product for being clean
and feeling moisturized so I would
probably take that and I would also take
my Smith and Colt lash dance mascara if
you loved this video don't forget to
subscribe
you